[Musique]
jean marie bigard
est ce que vous savez coudre je couds
très bien ouais je recouvre à l'occasion
du pique un peu à la machine puisque un
peu à la machine vous préférez la mer ou
la montagne
la mer ces interviews sans intérêt comme
ça on n'a pas d'emmerdés la presse quand
vous étiez petit vous aimer l'école
un
oui oui je mets jamais l'école où elle
est bien bonne réponse non j'aimais bien
l'école et j'ai l'impression qu'on veut
qu'il me trouve à
10 dont jean-marie truffât dumas
perceuse oh non on a
préféré les chats ou les chiens
j'ai les 2 way et vous y croyez à ce
truc un peu ouais j'aime bien je préfère
y croire que de ne pas y croire hec -
moins solide ouais tu mange beaucoup de
frites
répond pas c'est un con
dis moi que tu as pensé à fait toi sur
cette
crête pensait faire rentrer du fioul ah
oui t'as pas taper le gaz
mais il le faut ça c'est bien ça c'est
la phrase branché en ce moment j'ai
fauté en boîte de nuit et il faut que je
rende lorsqu'il me livre le fumé à 8
heures ça fait super branché dis moi ça
va toi en ce moment il est nul ton
interview sans intérêt et oui comme cela
pas dans merde qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
de la côte est
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu